-Welcome to "The Tonight Show."
Guys, before we get started,
does anyone here want to be
Speaker of the House?
[ Laughter and cheers ]
Yep, as of tonight's taping,
it's been three days and
nine votes, and we still don't
have a Speaker of the House.
[ Laughter ]
Before today's vote,
C-SPAN was like,
"We swear this is not a rerun."
[ Laughter ]
Right now, Kevin McCarthy is
so embarrassed, he went up to
George Santos and said, "Help me
create a new identity."
[ Laughter ]
McCarthy has lost nine times.
It is brutal.
I mean, there's a reason why
you only get three strikes
in baseball.
I mean, it's just hard to watch.
Nine? That's a lot.
That's somewhere between
COVID variants
and "Yellowstone" spin-offs.
Nine. Nine.
And get this -- I read that some
Democrats and Republicans are
considering a deal for a speaker
both parties can get behind.
-Ooh.
-So congratulations to our new
Speaker of the House,
"Top Gun: Maverick."
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's a good movie.
Meanwhile, McCarthy is now
in the negotiation phase
where he's making a bunch of
concessions with the Republicans
who are against him,
and one of those concessions is
a change to the rules that would
make it easier to remove him.
[ Laughter ]
You know it's bad when the only
way you can get hired is
if you promise to get fired,
you know what I'm saying?
'Course, with everything going
on in Washington, it's been
a busy week for news anchors,
and I think they need a break.
I mean, check out this clip of
Andrea Mitchell on MSNBC
earlier today.
-After a night spent offering
big concessions
to the never-Kevins, at the risk
of alienating
some of his original supporters
in the Republican caucus --
[ Gags ]
Excuse me.
[ Laughter ]
-Hey! Hey!
Wow.
[ Rim shot ]
[ Laughter ]
-And then, for the first time
in TV history,
a news anchor coughed up
a hair ball.
[ Laughter ]
That's the sound you make when
the doctors checks if you have
strep throat,
you know what I'm saying?
That's the sound
your ketchup bottle makes
when you try to squeeze out
the last drop.
[ Laughter ]
The closed captioning just
said... --
[ Laughter ]
Yep, Congress spent a third day
voting for
a new Speaker of the House,
and after so many rounds, I feel
bad for the people who have to
keep reading all the names of
the representatives
to get their vote.
-[ Scoffs ] You know what?
Don't feel bad. It's easy.
-I'm just saying it's tedious.
And some of the names are hard
to pronounce.
-Not when you're a professional
announcer like me.
Go ahead, test me.
-Okay, I guess I can.
I'll test you real quick.
Who's this?
-Okay, easy.
Jheri Curl.
-Alright.
[ Laughter ]
Okay, who's this?
-Come on. Barry Manilow.
Come on.
[ Laughter ]
Give me some harder ones.
Rapid-fire me.
-Okay. Here we go.
Who's this?
-Okay. David Schwimmer.
[ Laughter ]
Rihanna.
Lady Macbeth.
Bad Salmon.
Chips Ahoy.
[ Laughter ]
Frank Stallone.
Ah-ah-ah-choo.
[ Laughter ]
Oh, it's Scott Delivery,
it's DiGiorno.
[ Laughter ]
Ah-na-na-na-na, na-na-na,
na-na-na, na-na-na.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Na-na-na-na-nah.
♪ Lyrical gangster ♪
[ Applause ]
Nice Blunt Rotation.
[ Laughter ]
Oh, Yank Johnson.
Menage a Trois in Greece.
[ Laughter ]
Oh, Vicious Sharts. Ooh.
And Liar.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Thank you very much.
Steve Higgins, a professional.
Steve Higgins, everyone.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Everyone is weighing in on this.
Today, Elon Musk tweeted, "Kevin
McCarthy should be Speaker."
[ Laughter ]
It makes sense 'cause Kevin
McCarthy is a lot like a Tesla.
He was on the road to
his destination and then
suddenly veered off course.
[ Laughter ]
Meanwhile, President Biden
is staying out of
the Speaker drama, calling it
embarrassing but saying,
"That's not my problem."
[ Laughter ]
Then he added...
[ Applause ]
Biden then added...
[ Cheers and applause ]
Then he added...
At which point Biden just posted
the Kermit drinking tea meme.
There you go.
That's interesting.
[ Applause ]
Everybody's talking about this.
In his forthcoming book, Prince
Harry claims that Prince William
once knocked him to the floor
during an argument about Meghan.
[ Audience oohs ]
Apparently the fight happened at
the Buckingham Waffle Palace.
[ Laughter ]
It's fun when royals fight
'cause they keep their pinkies
out.
[ Laughter ]
Harry was shocked because
usually when they fight,
they just stand back and tell
their butlers what to do.
"Now, perhaps a knee
to the groin."
[ Laughter ]
"Choke him out, Jeeves."
Harry also writes
in his new book that before
he married Meghan, William and
Kate were religious viewers
of her show "Suits."
I feel like I believed
everything Prince Harry said
until just now.
[ Laughter ]
I don't think even
the stars of "Suits"
were religious viewers of
"Suits."
[ Laughter ]
Well, some movie news --
"Avatar: The Way of Water" has
officially passed
"Top Gun: Maverick"
to become
the number-one movie of 2022.
It is a huge, huge hit.
It made us wonder, what would
other classic movies look like
if they took place underwater?
Check this out.
[ Burbling ]
[ Laughter and applause ]
-There you go. That's it.
Pretty good. I'd watch that.
Well, listen to this -- I heard
that people on TikTok are
claiming that a great way
to beat the flu is
by sleeping with
potato slices in your socks.
There's a lot of questionable
medical advice online,
and depending on where you look,
you get pretty different
answers.
For instance, for the flu,
TikTok says...
Facebook says...
WebMD says...
[ Laughter and applause ]
Next up, for a cold,
TikTok says...
Twitter says...
WebMD says...
[ Cheers and applause ]
And finally, for COVID,
TikTok says...
Truth Social says...
And WebMD says...
I think just call a real doctor.
Guys, I read about
a new COVID variant
that has some people worried.
It's called XBB.1.5.
I guess they couldn't think of
a catchier name.
And it actually inspired me
to write a tiny song.
Roots?
♪♪
♪ There was Alpha, then Delta ♪
♪ Then Omicron next ♪
♪ But this latest variant
might be the best ♪
♪ It's XBB.1.5 ♪
♪ Another brand of COVID-19
has arrived ♪
♪ It's a new strain ♪
♪ But it isn't the same ♪
♪ Sounds more like
Elon Musk's kid's name ♪
♪ It's XBB.1.5 ♪
♪ Not UB40,
who sings "Red Red Wine" ♪
♪ Put on your mask when
you're inside a facility ♪
♪ It could be a robot from
a "Star Wars" trilogy ♪
♪ It's XBB.1.5 ♪
♪ Not OMG or MP3 or TCBY ♪
♪ Or an eye chart made by
a really high guy ♪
♪ Sounds like the password of
your parents' Wi-Fi ♪
♪ It's XBB.1.5 ♪
♪ XBB.1.5 ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Cheers and applause continue ]
That's the most applause
I've gotten in five years.
-Wow.
-Unbelievable.
Switching gears, a big consumer
electronics show just kicked off
in Las Vegas, and there are so
many new products on display,
including a self-driving
stroller that's powered
by artificial intelligence.
[ Laughter ]
The only question is, will it be
a billion-dollar lawsuit or
a trillion-dollar lawsuit?
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, the commercial says,
"Order one now before
we all get arrested."
But don't worry. It comes with
an override button
in case your baby needs to take
control of the stroller.
[ Laughter ]
Another interesting product
being unveiled is
the high-tech,
snore-silencing pillow.
[ Laughter ]
Although that's any pillow
if you hold it against
someone's face long enough,
you know what I'm saying?
[ Laughter ]
A pillow that stops you from
snoring, which has got to be
the most passive-aggressive gift
of all time.
[ Laughter ]
Stop.
And finally, a 19-year-old just
travelled nearly 2,000 miles
from Maine to Florida
on a unicycle.
[ Audience oohs ]
And much like his wheel,
it's a pretty safe bet
that he's single. Yeah.